Now as I mentioned earlier variables and
numbers can be combined. And when we do
this, we create expressions. An expression
is what you get any time you put numbers
and variables together, with mathematical
operators. So those are things like plus
minus divide and multiply. To make things
a little bit more concrete I'll write out
a few examples of expressions. So in each
of these expressions right here, you see
some terms that have variables in them.
Like 3x or, or -4m^4 / 13n^3.
And these are combined with terms that are
just numbers, like 4 or -2. The separate
things that we add or subtract to come up
with the expressions are called terms. Any
term that has a variable in it is called a
variable term like 7.8y / 3 or z and other
terms that don't have variables in them
that are just numbers are called constants
or constant terms. I've only labeled the
types of terms in the first expression but
we could easily figure out what kinds of
terms are in the other two expressions, as
well.